if i if i have sex with a woman right
this is something that i think a lot of
mistakes that women make is they
okay a guy will take her out on the date
they'll sleep together and she will
expect him
to text her back the next day honey why
are you playing hard to get he already
got you
you should be humbling yourself enough
to text the guy back
and want to reinitiate that contact
again because that tells me
this is a good woman that tells me this
is a woman who actually values like her
sexuality who actually values you know
what she has to offer and she wants to
just want to throw it away for nothing
she's like okay well i had a great time
with this guy i slept with this guy
like i want to keep him around so i
expect to see some level of commitment
okay light bulb bing just went off thank
you sterling you're saying that if you
have sex with a woman and okay let's say
that's a friday night
saturday rolls around she does not text
you
sunday rolls around she does not text
you
something's off yeah meaning she's
treating sexes like it's another
freaking tuesday yeah yeah she should be
texting you hey thanks for all the great
night blah blah blah love to see you
again love to see you again but when
they do not text you the next day
something's up yeah it's it it's it's
not it's not a hundred percent clear-cut
yeah it's like it's not scientific but
to me a lot of this is your gut
instincts that's my gut feeling natalia
as a beautiful lady
who may or may not have done anything
inappropriate on a friday night
is what he's saying makes sense like do
you typically
i'm not even saying sexually if a guy
takes you out on a nice date you guys
have a nice time together
from the mindset of a woman do you text
them the next day do you expect them to
text you how do you process this i mean
naturally you want them to text you
because
i mean i would think you want that you
would want that right but i mean i would
say you only want it because
if the person i mean the person i go out
with i would assume that they're also
wanted by others so when they show that
hey i'm gonna pick you and text you you
also feel like well then i'm gonna give
you the attention you need and then i
think eventually the tables turn i think
at that point that's when women become a
little bit more like texting all the
time and they can become more clingy
because once you show that it shows like
hey i you you probably know i'm
around right but i'm picking you so it's
just that that initiative that
leadership that like guys show that are
attractive to women like you know i mean
would i text a guy after a date sure i'd
text him like hey had a great time
whatever x y and z but
i don't know i just i would prefer a guy
to do it well this goes to the concept
of uh a man must attain the woman but
the woman must retain the man right
absolutely it's like like sex is not a
guarantee if she if i have sex with a
woman that's not a guarantee of a
relationship with her
that's like okay that's your entry thing
but if you don't have something okay
but you don't have sex with her do you
still expect her to text you
no i don't expect as much of a
commitment from a girl
if we haven't had sex yet oh okay
because for me to in my in my head like
i mean just in my experience once once
sex has happened that's when the dynamic
of the relationship will shift the power
dynamic very much
obviously shifts yes after you've had
sex with one for the first time and i
think i think men and women both
understand that instinctually and it was
funny you said that that you used the
word clinginess yeah before it's kind of
weird because because i'm not i'm
obviously not
around my woman 24 7.
i actually look for that clinginess kind
of behavior as a as a green flag for me
because i i it doesn't affect me because
i ain't around it 24 7. if i was around
at 24 7 that clinginess would be a bad
thing for me but if i'm not around a 24
7 if i see her like once every three
months that clinginess is actually
fantastic for me because that keeps her
loyal it keeps her invested in me that
means i ain't gonna worry about this
girl okay cool she's she's on the hook
she likes me like she's committed to me
she's falling in love with me so it's
like confirmation for yeah so i actually
kind of looked for that clinginess and
to a degree that's a that's a green flag
for you for me yes for a lot of men
because for me because because my my
relationship is very like and my
relationship is very low maintenance on
my end
right like i said i ain't hanging out
with all the time i'm seeing it once
every three months when i fly to europe
or something so like she has to be able
to put up with that
limited amount of time around me
and that's that's a mental test for her
she can't handle that okay she's not one
for me but if she can actually handle
that and accept that i'm not going to be
texting her back every time i'm not
going to be texting her 24 7. i'll tell
her i'll have and i miss her
every now and then but i'm not going to
be like on i've got i've got business to
run you know i don't have the time to
sit there and go back and forth all day
if she accepts she can accept that
limited if you can accept that the
limited amount of attention i do give
her is super valuable
then that's a good girl for me
but i think women who want men like that
they expect that like if i'm talking to
a guy and he's texting me too much so if
you like that clip click right here
for me
now we're gonna know like i'm working
more than you i need to go back
so like i could